[Music]
it's 6:45 in the morning I'm feeling it
it's ticking watch baby it's a special
day today I'm not on my way to pick up
Chris I'm actually on my way to pick up
Justin good Chris drive drive knock back
would you want him set up here Mike
Justin's in the back so last time we had
Chuckie Oh fried chicken it was
incredible
oh wow white like a potato chip this
really feels like southern meal but the
flavors are just all crazy I think it's
some of the best fried chicken I've ever
had gave us some peace some peace of
mind but today we're going to laptop or
doing it some Taiwanese spicy popcorn
chicken and Justin has actually been
here before
oh yeah look very much like a sit back
there
chicken watch chicken watch there's got
to go bye Jeff hey who are you and where
are we
I'm David I'm the owner of lotto and
today we will introduce the popcorn
chicken basically it's one of the most
popular street foods entire ones every
street corner you're gonna find a
popcorn chicken tree which everybody
makes it
yes it's like hotdogs in New York there
you go it's like a baby what is the
history of the Taiwanese popcorn chicken
according to legend a legend yeah the
owner of a chicken farm basically the
business was kind of slow and the rather
chicken leftover so uh they basically
chopped up a lot of those chickens and
start selling them as a fry popcorn
every part of the Buffalo style
[Music]
could you walk us through how to make
your popcorn chicken sort of step by
step at the beginning course you have to
cut the chicken into little pieces
then you marinate the chicken we have
about seven to ten different spices we
put in Minsk our legs Wow Mensa ginger
you want to use shovels ahead how are
you shovel there you go oh yeah some of
that yeah but then we add meet you which
is the Taiwanese rice one that's one of
the main ingredients and then there's
the star in it - I'm sorry star we are
star anis it does taste like anus that
would read them and then we are kind of
powdered them I just imagine that you
really would do like ten times this
amount right yeah yeah yeah I grew up
with two big sisters and they were so
mean to me just want to lay down a quick
wrap around where we're doing here quick
wrap yeah are you ready for this yeah
check it check it check it in this
kitchen
just making some check yeah yeah Keith
and Chris
given what kiss should we give them any
frien
no actually with far fried haar privacy
then we deep fine once this fry them
with season will pop on chicken powder
powder ooh a nice hard dust oh I got a
little dust out the nostrils but it
feels good one of the secret ingredients
they use I shouldn't be telling you that
we are doing another dish that used a
shiitake mushroom we use the Stuckey
juice to marinate the chicken so you're
gonna taste this this flavor in the
kitchen I want I just remembered last
time I was here was the last meal I had
with my ex-girlfriend
[Music]
a day later okay chicken doesn't make
people break up I hope not
oh we all hope not David it just hit I'm
sorry that he had them sorry to bring it
down
did she just want something less spicy
and you were delivering like a Taiwanese
level of spice I was delivering
Taiwanese level spice for sure and she
wanted something more mild yeah okay
lady not neither any now exactly that
you're just gonna dredge through it yeah
yeah that's right you gonna go slow yeah
yeah but no this place brought back
those memories suggestin we have a
rubric Chris penis the moisture the
salinity which is sort of the seasoning
Solan yeah we picked this out with that
for me it means salt content typically
the souk rock city we learned about
serenity remedy yeah we've misheard what
everything about there what's the other
one salt sometimes bad say Danity
salinity I love it that it's salty so
we're gonna start actually with the non
spicy we had to make an extra batch
without any slice just so we could taste
the flavors a little more so everybody's
stabbed a chick oh my god probably not
the best way to say it Gump a man
hmm it's awesome
mmm like the chew of it is like very
delightful red crunchy somersaulting
it's a little french fry is to me I'm
getting that through mommy mushroom
taste at the end it's like on my tongue
like I ate mushrooms takes me back to
the motherland Oh have you been
I'm of European descent but I've never
been to Europe
no one will invite me there is this a
little bit about it
no no do you want to make it about you
your chicken doesn't make people break
up I hope not
you know why do we try the mild this is
what they said is the only level we
should try is it this will be spicy
enough I just touched a little bit with
my tongue anyway like food I've plenty
of heat that's all your name it's a
little bit of a hot cheetos feeling
where you're in just later continue like
oh I'm not anymore because if I stop
I'll die the salt level is really nice
yeah really good singing oh my mouth's
getting hot
oh boy oh this has gotten much less
spicy than me just eating a cup of ice
really not opposite for me I'm sweating
look we could go to Europe I gotta go to
here look at the shape of this guy look
at him I mean you weren't at that level
2 is gonna be pretty hot yeah he said
this would be more than enough
and we shouldn't beat this Gombe ok come
back
oh yeah oh well there it is there it is
I was like it tastes like the previous
one and then now and now it hates it a
longer it hits the top and the sides of
the tongue whoa how spicy is this spicy
chicken oh there's a bunch of spices at
least like seven to ten different spices
go into it maybe how landrace changed my
palate but that's not crazy spicy do you
think you can handle the third level I
kind of didn't want to try it I was
gonna let you guys just try it but now
that this wasn't that bad i'ma go for it
usually you're saying you're gonna back
out at the last minute I already told
you imminent you didn't want to be up by
7:15 and then at 7:30 was 738 well you
tried to put me in the back seat
probably supposedly the driver of the
car and all of a sudden I'm in the back
seat there's a new car in the
relationship you use the new car this
chicken doesn't make people break up
right go really wow really yeah let's
just ignore the problem
[Music]
I'm really really really even singer
with it yeah I'm really really really
insecure with it possibly women we have
four levels non-spicy mile median extra
spice but we also have a Taiwanese spicy
so some of these chicken pieces are
significantly redder than others I think
kind of a rattle and I think we'd be
willing to go all the way to the
Taiwanese level of spice you don't want
to go this I don't want to go not even
like one bite no come back okay I'm
ready for it
oh boy that one does taste different
yeah I trust the chef yeah got to do it
and you're like I won no you're wrong
Wow yeah it tastes like peppers uh-huh
that's crazy
didn't say he was wrong woo oh you have
the Asian customers coming I warned them
about extra spicy and as they do it and
they come they came back like you're
right she's just go medium who is it
different that perspective it is top of
there right now my eyebrow is getting
head it hot it hurts a lot but there's
something to it it's like you got a
little hit of that that's spicy
hello want it again this up here I know
it hurts me a lot but I don't know I can
eat the fire I can do anything
hey you ought to take another ride I
just don't I just don't to live in fear
I like that it's kind of like a
relationship hey we've got some friends
a you wanna come eat some chicken with
us come here true spicy
[Music]
[Applause]
we can tell you about it wasn't a spicy
chicken watch King it Wow cuz you're the
good fat Thanks you wanna toss one to me
yeah okay I mean I'm sorry about
everything that happened earlier use one
hand to hold in one hand and pour it I
heard him okay I'm just okay kind of
like I was pushing you away but I was
also late so let's put the stink of our
relationship and you catching this
chicken
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they're only Justin is Marlene
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations bud you're great you're
free free man he made it it's just a
drawing I drawing has no power over you
anymore no definitely not
chickens about rebirth renewal that's
what I always say which came first
chicken to the egg maybe they came
together
[Music]
yeah sometimes get a crack an egg to
make an omelet don't count your chickens
before they hatch because you just don't
know if there might be two chickens in
one of the eggs why did the chicken
cross the road to get to the other side
of what their relationships chicken
watch 2k15 chicken is the best fried
chicken I won't say that because we're
always improving on the vision we take a
little bit every other two weeks you
keep on doing proofing that's how you do
this is definitely the most snackable
fried chicken that I've had in a long
time
and it's really good fried chicken oh
it's great fried chicken and normally I
don't want to be a bummer but normally
I'm only about the bone in you know I
don't I don't even [ __ ] around and stuff
those my bones in it miss I can [ __ ]
with this mm-hmm no I'm saying it's
possible
Dora
way too hot star it is a Taiwanese
chicken fast-food joint
how do you guys not just share your
brains out on the show oh no that's part
of it it's also not the chase to my fear
and it's also not the shape of my dad is
also not the taste of my Pig chicken
watch to get 18
[Music]